[Applause]
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
new york governor kathy hokel signed a
bill this week that requires all used
cars to have working airbags the issue
is close to her heart because she spent
years working alongside a working airbag
[Applause]
amazon recently announced that fully
vaccinated employees can stop wearing
face masks at work but they'll still be
required to wear a ball and chain
it's amazon yeah
now it was announced this week that the
donald j trump highway beautification
sign in new york's upper west side is
being removed but just for fun let's all
say it's being evicted
[Applause]
during the recent u.n climate summit in
scotland president biden reportedly let
out a quote
long loud fart in front of britain's
duchess camilla parker bowles now that
is a real thing that really happened
here to comment on it is queen elizabeth
ii
[Music]
thank you president biden's behavior at
the recent u.n summit was improper and
appalling it is completely inappropriate
for a head of state to
[Laughter]
uh you were saying
i was saying that it is completely
inappropriate for a head of
it is
completely
itchy is coming
[Music]
what was that
what was what
would you like to leave very much so yes
ladies and gentlemen her royal majesty
queen elizabeth ii
i tried
i tried i couldn't make it
that's the only time i've made it
through that thing
okay moving on
session missy elliott received a star
this week on the hollywood walk of fame
but sadly they flipped it and reversed
it
i haven't story a lot yeah
you're right i can't oh my god
derek's crying real
tears sometimes farts make you cry real
too
you guys
a college football game in arizona was
paused last weekend after a fox ran onto
the field
and i'd do it again
put my face on a nice slim body thank
you
los angeles residents this week had to
show proof of vaccination to eat in
restaurants said people in los angeles
oh i don't eat
but i do so they put my body on a nice
tiny figure and finally
online searches for men's shapewear have
reportedly increased by
156 percent which explains why terex
waste is so snatched
and that was a monologue did you like
that monologue derrick yes sir
derek and a little corset you didn't
know you were into that but you are now
now friends we're done with the
monologue but we're not done with the
news
this week people magazine announced 2021
sexiest man alive which to everyone's
shock and surprise is not chris evans
wait
i'm sorry who is this that's chris evans
sorry everybody this is jenny she's my
head writer and she chooses the pictures
that go over my shoulder jenny this is
not chris evans oh right chris evans
you wanted chris evans
who is that very handsome actor named
chris right right right right right
handsome actor named chris found it
that's chris pratt oh
found it that's chris pine
found it
this christopher lloyd you were closer
the first time
right right okay i knew that handsome
chris coming right up him
that's christopher columbus
him
that's kris krangle
him
that's white jesus christ pam okay now
you're just doing any old thing and him
absolutely not him
no him no him no him no
jenny what is happening all right fine
i'm sorry
look
i'm gay which you know because i've told
you and because of everything you wear
and say right
well
because i'm gay i
i can't tell men apart
what
they all look exactly the same to me
between their neck and their hairline
it's just a blank space
so you don't even know who chris evans
is no to quote the great kiki palmer
sorry to this man
okay
but
then can you tell these two men apart
that's two identical twins
jenny that's ryan reynolds and your dad
i don't see it
that explains the graphics honestly it's
fine once you've seen one man you've
seen them all but wait you can see
terrick's face right oh
yeah
i can for sure see terrick's face it's
definitely not an endless void
oh good i'm glad you can see it because
i can't wait well moving on
congress this weekend finally passed the
one trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill and while this bill
will provide funding for more
traditional hard infrastructure projects
a second soft infrastructure bill
focused on social welfare and climate
change is still languishing in congress
what's the big deal what this country
really needs are new roads and bridges
sorry that's one of my writers and ian i
disagree
hard infrastructure is great but
personally i think we need something a
little
softer
softer
how do you mean
can i get a mic
[Music]
we need a little medicare
medicaid
some parental leave that is fully paid
can you do it
all
right i'm talking free child care and
pre-k forget it
each and every parent gets a child tax
credit babe
okay i think i see where you're coming
from
taxing billionaires lowering drug crisis
and while we're at it might solve the
climate crisis
[Music]
okay okay soft infrastructure does sound
pretty nice but
for my money i still think we need
something a little
harder
harder how do you mean can i get a mic
[Music]
i want them to pave my road i want my
subway full i want them to fix my bridge
and fill my whole pothole oh
okay so like significantly harder i want
a new highway system so the traffic
doesn't funnel and i want them to start
digging on every one of my tunnels okay
again i think we get the gist
internet access pay it with my taxes
somebody fix my pipes and nasty okay
did you do it
was it too hard
yeah and that was a little too hard i'm
sorry
i guess the lesson is that we need both
hard and soft infrastructure
well the real lesson is not to just be
handing us microphones
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you